it's the winter of 1890 dr. William
Halstead is the chief surgeon at Johns
Hopkins Hospital the scrub nurse under
Halsted a woman named Caroline Hampton
begins to develop a severe reaction to
the strong disinfectants used to scour
her hands and arms before surgery
Halstead takes an interest in her plight
in a moment of vision he asks Goodyear
rubber company to experiment with the
production of a pair of thin rubber
gloves they fit Caroline
well like gloves and her hands begin to
recover in fact the gloves are such a
success that the good doctor orders more
for his team and for himself from these
early experiments a multi-billion dollar
rubber glove industry is born and it
turns out the doctor didn't just want to
protect the nurses hands he also wanted
to take them in holy matrimony Halsted
and Caroline were married just a few
months after he gave her that first pair
of gloves